[Music]
in today's eight on your side the
pandemic has had a profound effect on
higher education
we caught up with ryan lufkin of canvas
the leading technology used by thousands
of colleges and universities in remote
learning
to get his insight on what's to come for
students and teachers post-pandemic
he says the days of the large-scale
lecture halls you know with 300-plus
students are numbered the days of those
very very large courses
in person are done i think we're going
to see a lot more
fully online courses for those very
large courses
um schools will focus on smaller courses
and things like that because uh
you know if we're going to bring people
together it should be in smaller groups
it should be in ways that they can
engage better
luvkin says we'll see a lot more of the
blended learning approach through
technology all course materials will be
online and assignments as well as
resources that students need access to
while in-person lectures and discussions
will still be available in person
he says colleges and universities have
spent the past year looking at better
ways as well to help
students get jobs we're seeing a lot
more college universities looking at
how do we provide lower cost options
lower time intensive options
beyond a two or four year degree maybe
it's a certificate program
maybe it's just a skills course how do
we offer those for
adult learners and you know maybe
students that are looking for the
fastest path of jobs
we're seeing a lot more of that that's
one of the major trends in education
right now
he adds they've been studying the
student user experience over the past
year to see how they can better design
their online courses and offer them with
greater consistency